what was it like working with Jordan
Jordan pill was uh amazing he's he's
he's a comic so like yeah I uh like a
couple I think last week because I'm on
like a um uh social media break I gave
myself a break so I haven't been on
social media for the last three four
days is um was there anything that
happened or do you just take periodic
breaks you know it just felt like it's
too much going on and I feel like every
time I grab my phone before I look at
anything a text from my kids anything
I'm looking at Instagram it didn't make
any sense and so the last few days have
been pretty
chill I found apps on my phone that I
didn't know I
had what like random games like
oh so you know it's it's been so I've
been doing that but like you know once
again work I I posted a get out clip
before I went on my break uh like Jordan
had me do all these alt uh bits at the
end of the movie yeah yeah and most
people don't realize it wasn't written
he had just walk up to me give me a
scenario and then I'll just go with it
that's great and so and that was so much
and he'll be just cracking up walking to
the car like okay uh your aun single I'm
like what all right and then whatever
that means yeah you know and so that
that that was so much fun rejoin doing
that no was cuz I I only know him as an
actor and as a friend you know I don't
I've never he's never directed me in
anything what is he like a as a director
like he is his notes clear his notes are
clear and he's you could tell he's been
on the other side of this yeah and so he
treats he literally figured out
everybody's process and work with all of
us differently it wasn't like this you
know some directors like this is the one
way and I want all you guys to work this
way yeah he literally figured out all
our processes and just like show love to
that so like with me our process was
well you can do you know do what's
written then we'll do a rail take and
because you let me have that I'll do
whatever you want yeah cuz you let me
know that I could do something if I
figur want to do something on my own it
was cool yeah yeah I knew him when he
had no car oo he would walk to Matt TV
sometimes he would not not be wearing
only one
shoe he had no furniture but he had like
he used to collect those you know like
you go to Hot Topic you see like a
porcelain white you me scary like doll
you know what I mean he'd have a couple
of those on a shelf right he would just
smoke weed all day and we talk about
video games like he got me into
morrowwind it was before yeah it was
just we were at a GameStop once he like
I'm telling you right now man you know
what I mean there's no way in your head
you would think oh this guy is going to
be the next
Spielberg ner there's no way there was
just not even you know I mean and then
it's like then when you when I saw when
I went to we went to the note Premiere
yeah and he went up and they did that
little um speech and I was s sitting
next to um kalala and also Ike baral's
and I teared up I was like oh God look
at him incredible it's incredible it's
it's it's so funny when he first told
told me about get out was at a party wow
and I was like I just looked at him like
he was like yeah I wrote a horror film
I'm like oh that's nice you know what I
mean like sure you did yeah yeah yeah
and and but it's so in because like I
look at it from that perspective too cuz
I met Jordan at Montreal yeah uh years
ago like we was drunk in one of those
like you know parties and just talking
[__] with two guys or glasses and
[__] yeah dumb ass baseball had
something like [__] it could have
been a sketch cuz we just
kept tell you what's going to happen but
that's where that's where you got the
movie yeah you didn't get the movie when
he got the movie you got the movie years
before yeah at that bar in Montreal he
was just and he was just telling me what
he he was into he was a [__] horror
fan and then when you go back and look
at somebody the sketches you like yo
some of those sketches were really
dark oh that sketch where it's like the
Keegan plays a insult comic okay and
Jordan is like you know what I mean a
handic what he is right and he got M me
you know what I mean if you really think
about that [__] right that sketch
it's dark it's messed up it's [__] up
you remember the sketch where keeg is
like an aerobics guy yeah
yeah aerobics guy like they show like
like what of the the familyes
dead yeah it's so yeah yeah because they
you know what you what's what's great
about those two too is like um they're
just they they live in two different
worlds many worlds mhm they know so much
about so many things like ke you know
was a you know a religious guy pasture
you I mean he would go to like res
Renaissance Fairs but he also can you I
mean go to a you know hip-hop concert I
mean they just they just lived in
different worlds and they were so bright
they have so much information that it's
just like when they got together I
remember the day got they got together I
was like oh no this is going to be this
is like bigger than Wham or you you did
you see that like you saw that they like
when you know Mad TV was it did you see
them two like so this is what
happened this is what happened this is
what happened this is what so ke